اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه من العربيه والتي نخصص معظمها
لتغطيه التطورات في السودان ونبداها
بالعناوين
[موسيقى]
اشتباكات متقطعه وحياه شبه طبيعيه في
الخرطوم وام درمان وحصيره قتل المدنيين
تتجاوز 440
-
بوقت فوري
رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق يدعو للحوار
عاجل ومفاوضات شامله بين البرهان
ايضا
تصف اسرائيلي فلسطيني متبادل 20 صاروخان
اطلقت من غزه واخرى عليها
كيف تستعد كيف تستعد للهجوم المضاد وروسيا
تؤكد ان اوكرانيا فقدت 15000 جنديين خلال
الشهر الماضي
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا مع استمرار خلق الهدن
المعلنه منذ بدء الاشتباكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع كشفت نقابه اطباء السودان
عن سقوط
447 قتيلا
و2,255 مصابا من المدنيين منذ بدء
اشتباكات في الخامسه عشر من الماضي وبث
الاوضاع الطبيه في تفاقم مستمر حيث خرجت
عشرات المستشفيات عن الخدمه فيما باتت
المخازن الطبيه فارغه في بعض الولايات ومع
هذا الوضع لم يجد استودعون الا النزوح
سبيلا حيث قالت الامم المتحده ان نحو نصف
مليون سوداني فرو داخلي وخارجيا منذ منتصف
ابريا الماضي هذا ويعاني اخرون ممن قرروا
البقاء من ابسط الخدمات الاساسيه من غذاء
ومياه وكهرباء فيما يبقى ازيز رصاصي
مسموعا وان كان بشكل متقطع
لازم اشتغل يعني في الظروف
السلع زادوا في زياده اي حاجه زائده لازم
انا اشتغل
ايوه
زي ساعتين ثلاثه
لانه البلد ما امنه
الشعبي طبعا
يحاول يستغل القواد ما حبابه والخوف ما
منه فايده
[موسيقى]
بالتفاصيل قالت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان
الله انها اسقطت الطائره من طراز ميجا
تابعه للجيش السوداني في الخرطوم وذكرت
قوات الدعم السريع انها تصدت لغارات عده
شنها الجيش السوداني صباح اليوم على مناطق
سكنيه في الخرطوم
هذا واظهرت الصور واستهداف الطيران الجيش
السوداني لاهداف وتمركزات تابعه لقوات
الدعم السريعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عم احمد اخر التطورات انه الان هناك
طائرات تحلق في سماء الخرطوم وبالتحديد في
وسط الخرطوم في هذه الاثناء طائرات تتبع
للقوات الجويه السودانيه مع الاستماع
لمضادات مضادات ارضيه تتبع للدعم السريع
بصوت عالي جدا وما زالت حتى الان تحلق هذه
الطائرات في هذه المنطقه وسط الخرطوم في
هذه اللحظات
ربما هناك استهداف لكن لم تظهر لنا الصوره
حتى الان اي او لم نرى حتى الان اي موقع
تم استهدافه وانما فقط نستمع الى اصوات
للطائرات ونستمع كذلك الى المضادات
الارضيه ربما هذا هو ابرز الاحداث او اخر
الاحداث تطورا فيما يتعلق
بالاستهداف الذي تقوم به اول الحملات التي
تقوم بها قوات الجويه السودانيه
والدعم السريع والتصدي الدعم السريع لها
بالمضادات الارضيه كذلك هذه في هذه
الاثناء وفي هذه اللحظات ما زالت تستمر
حتى الان تحليق هذه الطائرات وحتى
المضادات الارضيه كذلك
قوه الدعم السريعه اعلنت اليوم انها اسقطت
طائره ميجا التابعه الجيش السوداني هل صدر
من الجيش السوداني او من اي مصدر مستقل ما
ينفي او يؤكد هذه الروايه
نعم لم يصدر حتى الان احمد
لتاكيد او اثبات او نفي ذلك لكن ما هو
معلوم انها صدرت من قوات الدعم السريع صدر
هذا التصريح بانهم استطاعوا اسقاط هذه
الطائره
وتحدثوا كذلك عن انهم بعد انهم بعد اسقاط
هذه الطائره تحدثوا قبلها في بيانات اخرى
نفو امور ذكرها الجيش السوداني فيما يتعلق
بالاذاعه والتلفزيون وغيرها كذلك لكن حتى
هذه اللحظه لا توجد اي تفاصيل كثيره الان
الطائره ليست بعيده من هنا احمد وهي وكذلك
المضادات الارضيه كذلك ربما تستمع اليها
الان نسمع لصوت معك الان
[موسيقى]
احمد هذه الطائرات تحلق وسط الخرطوم
تحلق وسط الخرطوم واتجهت جنوبا
وربما تكون هنالك اهداف جنوبيه الخرطوم
تستهدف هذه الطائره نرى اعمده الدخان
لكنها بعيده جدا من هذه المنطقه في اقصى
جنوب الخرطوم هذه اعمده الدخان التي نراها
من هذه المنطقه اقصى جنوبيه الخرطوم كذلك
جنوب غرب الخرطوم في هذه اللحظات وربما
تكون هذه اعمده الدخان من استهداف
الطائره التي تحلق الان فوق سماء الخرطوم
طيب هو تحليق الطيران بصوره عامه فوق
الخرطوم يعني هل دائما ياتي قبل التنفيذ
هجمات يعني يبان هل يمكن فقط ان يكون
الاستكشاف والرصدم انه يعني ان هناك هجوم
سينفذ في اي لحظه
كلا الامرين صحيح احمده احيانا يقول فقط
للاستهداف واحيانا يكون كذلك فقط لكي رصد
او يقوم برصد المناطق التي تتمركز بها
قوات الدعم السريع لان الجيش السوداني
يمتلك طيران للرست والطيران كذلك
للاستهداف بانواع مختلفه وهذا ايضا يدفعنا
للحديث احمد على انها سلاح الطيران من
الاسلحه القويه جدا التي يمتلكها الجيش
السوداني بل يعتبر من اقوى الاسلحه وهذا
ما ثبت في هذه الحرب فعليا بالنسبه
للعمليات التي تقوم بها القوات الجويه
السودانيه واستهدافها لمواقع الدعم السريع
وقمل وقيامها بحملات مكثفه بين الفين
والاخرى على المواقع التي تتمركز بها هذه
القوات بالامس كانت هنالك حمله عنيفه جدا
قامت بها القوات الجويه السودانيه نفذت
العديد من الضربات في مناطق متفرقه ابرزها
كان في محيط مطار الخرطوم ومحيط القياده
العامه للجيش وكذلك استهداف في ام درمان
كذلك في محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون كذلك في
مدينه بحري في كارفور مربع سته وبالقرب من
المعسكر الذي يتبع لقوات الدعم السريع
طيب سالم بالنسبه للاهداف التي تقصف عاده
هي اهداف تتحدث عن اهدافنا عسكريه هل هناك
ايضا استهداف لاهداف مدنيه كما تدعم في
بيان له اليوم بان الجيش السوداني استهدف
بالطيران المستشفى شرق النيل
نعم ذكر الدعم السريع هذا الامر بان الجيش
السوداني يستهدف مواقع مدنيه وانه قد
استهدف مستشفى شرق النيل لكن قبل هذا قبل
هذا البيان كان قد ذكر الجيش السوداني في
احدى بياناته بحديثه على ان قوات الدعم
السريع هي
حولت مستشفى شرق النيل الى مكان عسكري
وانها تدير منه عمليات عسكريه لذلك ربما
كان هذا البيان استباقي كان يفهم منه انه
يمكن استهداف هذه المنطقه ما دام الجيش
السوداني نظر الى ان هذا المستشفى لم يعد
مستشفى وانما عاد منطقه عمليات تتبع لقوات
الدعم السريعه
اذا سكتفي بهذا القدر نكون معك في متابعه
متابعه دائمه لكل هذا التطورات العربيه
السالم الهاشمي شكرا سالم
مشاهدينا وكما ذكرنا قبل قليل فقد اتهم
بيان لقوات الدعم السريع اتهم الجيش
بالتسبب في مقتل وجرح العشرات من
المواطنين بعد قصف مستشفى شرق النيل
بالطيران الحربي واوضحت قوات الدعم
السريعه والحسابها على تويتر ان القصف
بالطيران شمير المستشفى شرق النيل الى
جانب عدد من المصانع في المنطقه الصناعيه
بحري وعدد من المنشات المدنيه والطبيه
والعسكريه
الناس لازم تهدا يشوفوا طريقه انه يحل
الموضوع ده لو ما قدروا يحلوا الموضوع ده
انا بتطلب من الامم المتحده تتدخل تشوف
امر لاحمتي ولا البرهان
[موسيقى]
وفي محاوله لمواجهه حاله الانفلات مستمره
جراء الاشتباكات اعلنت الشرطه السودانيه
للتامين الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه
والاحياء كما اشارت الشرطه الى قيامها
بحملات خلال الايام الثلاثه الماضيه في
عدد من مناطق جنوب الخرطوم بمشاركه
بمشاركه وتنسيق امني المشترك مع القوات
المسلحه
مشاهدينا في الاستوديو معي الان الصحفيه
السودانيه في جريده الشرق الاوسط الرحمان
يوسف اهلا بك
هذه المواجهات في تقديرك هي ماضيه نحو
الحسم ام نحو دارنا نقول ان تكون حرب
استنزاف بين الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش
السوداني شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه تحيه
لك والتحيه
للمشاهدين الاعزاء للاسف الشديد
يعني القراءه الوضع الان تدل على ان الحرب
ستستمر
بدليل واضح ان الطرفان يحاولان ان
بيانات التي تحاول تدعم رؤيه كل طرف في
الانتصار والانتصار تعني بمعنى اخر
المقابله الهزيمه وهنا والهزيمه والانتصار
الان هم يعني من صلاحات المشتركه بين
الطرفين اليوم عندنا في جريده الشرق
الاوسط الزميل علي ضروسي جرى حضار مع
رئيس رئيس قوات الدعم السريع اعتقد كل
الافادات التي خرج بها في هذا الحوار لا
تخرج عن اطار بيانات يعني تضخها بين
الاخرى وهو نفس الاتجاه الذي بدا به من
بدايه الحرب ولم ينتهي به حتى الان الكلام
يتجه نحو مزيد من
الاشتباكات ومزيد من المعارك
اللثه الهزيمه وهذه مصطلحات يعني تتنافى
مع
الهدنه وتتنافى مع التحضير الحوار وتتنافى
اللجوء الى شكل من الاشكال الاستقرار
لمعالجه الوضع السوداني ورابط اليه يعني
عطفا عليه ورغم تفجر هذه الازمه وصول
العلاقه بين الرجلين البرهان
الى هذه المرحله الا ان البرهان الملاحظه
انه لم يصدر لم يصدر حتى الان
باعفاء محمد حمدان دقومي بمصيبه كنائب له
الى ما يعود ذلك في تقديرك اعتقد يعود الى
ان يكون هناك مجال الى الحوار يعني الحوار
انت تحاور بشخص تعترف به ولكن اذا لا
تعترف في صحب ان يكون لك وجهه نظر حواريه
او قبول بالحوار كما فعلت قبل ذلك
فعل الرئيس ترامب عندما يعني يصنف
الحوثيين بجماعه ارهابيه وعندما نجعل
للحوار اشترط عليه بعض صخور
يعني تحذف هذه الصفه صفه الارهاب حتى يكون
هناك مجال للتعاور مع شخص تعترف به وان
كان يعني هو يتناقض مع افكارك وتشعر بانه
هو ليس حتى على حق مساله اقاله السيد هي
مساله اعتقد ممكن تقول لاحقا
اذا استمر الوضع عليه صار هناك في حوار
اعتقد هناك شروط صعبه جدا تحقيقها تجاه
القوات الدعم السريع المطالبه بالدمج
القوات السريع في الجيش يمكن تكون هذه
المعطله كبيره تواجه لانه هو يتطلع الى ان
يكون هو القوه العظمى في
هذا المطلب من الماضي ام ان الوضع الحالي
سيعزز بمطالب الجيش
البيانات السابقه منذ شهور تتحدث عن
اتجاهنا وهذا الطموح واعتقد هناك بعض
اخوتنا في قوى الحريه والتغيير غزو هذا
الفهم وزرع فيه البزره هذه وشعرت بانه
يمكن ان يكون بديل شرعي للاسف الشديد هذا
لا يمكن الشعب لن يرضى بغير مؤسسه معروفه
منذ زمان اكثر من كمال العقود مؤسسه
عسكريه وطنيه واختلفنا عنها الجيش زي ما
يقولون ليس جيش برهان الجيش السودان وهو
امتداد لن الدفاع السودان التي حاربت في
الحرب العالميه والتي بمشاركتها السلطان
استقلال طيب
من جديد
بتصريحات عضو مجلس السياده السودانيه
مشيرا على ان المشيرا الى ان الدعم السريع
يحتمي بوجوده بالاحياء المدنيه المكتظه
بالمدنيين وله قناصه لحمايته متحدثا عن
خطه استراتيجيه للقضاء عليه خلال اسبوعين
على حد قوله
وصلت
اما العاصمه القوميه والتي تم حجز معظم
قوات الخونه والعماله المتمردين فيها فلا
زالت المعارك جاهزه وقواتنا المسلحه
متوازنه ومتماسكه تحقق انتصارات متتاليه
على العدو المتمرد تمثل التي يحتمي قوات
التمرس فهو يحتمل بمنازل المواطنين
المواطنين المدنيين وبعض المستشفيات وبعض
المدارس خاصه في الاحياء المختصه
بالمدنيين ايضا احتماءهم وفي مناطق فيها
منشات حيويه يزعم
لا تتعرض للتدمير ايضا احيانا يتحركون من
مكان لاخر في بسرعه كبيره في طرق الطرق هي
اماكن التي يقضي فيها المدنيين حاجاتي
ومعايشهم وايضا تستخدم لاجلاء البعثات
الاجنبيه
وعلى الاسلحه المنازل في الاحياء المكتظه
بالسكان ايضا يوجد قناصه لحمايتهم عشان
كده التعامل معهم يكون صعب لكن الان هيئه
القوات المسلحه تضع الخطط الكفيله
بتدميرهم نهائيا
واكد عضو مجلس السياده السوداني الفريق
اول ياسر العطاء العربي ان اي وساطه
للتفاوض مع الدعم السريع غير ناجحه وان
الجيش يريد اخضاعه لسلطه الدوله موجهه
شكره للسعوديه ومصر ودوله جنوب السودان
على جهدهم
الشقيقه وجمهوريه الجنوب السودان ودولت
ومنظمه الايجاد على جهدهم في ذلك الامر
لكن لكن تاكد تمام اخي الكريم ان الوضع
الان هو وضع عمليات البحث حتى
التكرار ظهور رئيس الوزراء السابق عبد
الله حمدوك في المشهد في هذا التوقيت الى
ما تعزه هل هو تمهيد لدور قد يد يلعبه
الرجل في المرحله المقبله
والله اعتقد ربما ولكن انا اعتقد من يعني
الوفاء بمكان ان يظهر في الساحه ويتحدث
كونه كان اخر رئيس وزراء مدني وكان متفق
عليه قبل ان يستقيل وبالتالي
ومضى وهو متحسرا للاسف لانه انا في رايي
الشخصي يعني السبب في فشل عندهم الحريه
والتغيير وليس البرهان شديد لانه تعلق
عليه في توزيع الوزراء بشكل سلس
ومبنى على الكفاءه اكثر من الترضيات
السياسيه
التي يعني نجتمع رائحتها دائما في اروقه
الاجتماعات التي تجمع قوى الحريه والتغيير
اعتقد انطوك استقاله مرغما شعربا له رجل
لا يستطيع ان يقدم شيء لهذا التعنت ونظل
هذا الفهر القاصر والرويه القاصره وذهب
ولكن قلبه على على وطنه مهما كان لابد له
ان يخرج بان يقول القوله يساله وشعب منها
يوما وهذا لا يضر ان جاء رئيس الوزراء
مره اخرى اعتقد المساله تعتمد على
الاجواء التي سوف تسفر عنها الايام
المقبله اذا كان هناك حوار انطلق فعلا
بضيافه المملكه العربيه السعوديه او جنوب
افريقيا هناك سته طبعا مبادرات من بينها
مبادره السعوديه الامريكيه نعتقد انه اذا
كان حدث شيء من الحوار وانتهى الى يعني
اتفاق بين الطرفين
وبالتالي بالتاكيد سيكون هناك يعني
الاتفاق شكل
تشكيل الحكومه انتقاليه يكون فيها
المدنيون جزء منها عصير ولكن يجب ان يكون
قد وعد يجب ان يقول وعدوا الى مستوى الحدث
حتى يكون هناك مجال لانقاذ السودان من
الوحده التي وقع فيها اين هي الجامعه
العربيه من مساتين قاده السودان عطفا على
ما يمر به الان نتحدث عن 18 يوما من هذه
المواجهات واكتفت الجامعه العربيه حتى
الان باجتماعاتنا على مستوى المندوبين ما
قراتك لذلك للاسف جامعه الدول العربيه
ماتت منذ
الثلاث لاعات الخرطوم الثلاث ولم تكن اي
قمه اخرى بمستوى هذه اللغات الثلاث قبل ان
يكسر طوقها البرهان فيما بعد
واعتقد ذلك انعكاس للحاله العربيه العامه
لانه هناك كثير من الدول العربيه خرجت على
الخدمه يعني حصلت فيها مشاكل وهزيمات بسبب
خارجي او داخلي يعني
نرى اليمن عليه الان نرى سوريا مع عليه
الان نرى العراق لبنان ليبيا وهذه يعني
فلسطين
التي هي يعني تقيب وتختفي في ظل الازمات
الاخرى العالميه فهذا
هذه الازمات وهذا
التحقق في النسيج العربي نجم عنه ضعف
الجامعه العربيه الجامعه العربيه لم تقم
بمستوى الجامعه العربيه في ستنايات واعتقد
ان لما يعني انا اعول على القمه العربيه
القادمه التي
ستضيفها السعوديه
هي الدوله الان التي تستطيع بما تتمتع به
المقاومات وقدرات ان تقود الامه العربيه
الى رتقا نسيت مره اخرى ومن ثم جمع الصف
العربي وبعد ذلك ستكون الجامعه العربيه هي
لها القدره على اصدار قرارات يعني تخفي
بالغرض الى حد ما اذا كان هناك هزيمات
داخليه او ازوات خارجيه تستطع ان تسهل
فيها بشكل افضل
شكرا لك يا ضيفي في الاستوديو الصحفي
السوداني في ج ريده الشرق الاوسط فتح
الرحمن يوسف لحضورك
وفي متابعه التطورات الاوضاع الصحيه قال
المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن ان 39 مستشفى خرجت عن
الخدمه منذ بدء الاشتباكات مؤكده للعربيه
ان قوات الدعم السريع حولت بعض المستشفيات
لثقنات عسكريه عبد الرحمن دعا الى فتح
ممرات انسانيه لاغاثه الضحايا
مسلسلات التي توقفت على الخدمه منذ صباح
يوم 15 وحتى اليوم هي 39 مستشفى هذه
المستشفيات هي في مناطق الاشتباكات حتى
تاريخ اليوم مناطق غير امنه هي المستشفيات
التي متاخمه لمناطق الاشتراك شارع القصر
وشارع
المطار والقياده والاذاعه ومركز ومركز
البحري
في المقابل قال سكرتير ونقابه اطباء
السودان عطيه عبد الله العربي ان كل
المستشفيات العامه في الخرطوم توقفت عن
العمل بسبب عدم توفر الوقود مشددا ان الحل
الوحيد الى الوضع الانساني هو وقف القتال
حيث وصف الاوضاع الصحيه بالكارثيه
الاوضاع في الجنينه كارثيه للغايه نعم
النظام الصحي الى زال يتهاوى الى سقوط في
كل لحظه وحين بالامس عدد من المستشفيات
خرجت خارج الخدمه لانه لم نستطيع ايصال
كوادر طبيه اليها وبعض الاخر خرج من
الخدمه لانقطاع الوقود الجازلين وايضا
هنالك يعني عدد من الولايات تعاني من نقص
في الاكسجين حتى في ولايه الخرطوم
في عوامل مجتمعه وهو ما ظللنا ان نحذر منه
منذ اليوم الاول ستؤدي الى الى نتيجه لا
نتمناها ابدا وهي انهيار النظام الصحيه
نحن نتخوف ان يحدث مع يعني يحصل ما حدث
الجنينه في عدد من المدن وهو ما تخوف عنه
لذلك نحن مطالبتنا لطرفي الصراع الان هي
ايقاف هذه الحرب داخل الولايات الخرطوم
هنالك مستشفيات توقفت تماما لانه ما فيها
معينات طبيه
مع ثمار المواجهات بات النزوح هو الحل
امام الاف السودانيين هرب من القتال
الدائر في هذه الاثناء كشفت بيانات
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره الى نزوح اكثر من
300 واربعه الف شخص داخل السودان منذ بدء
الاشتباكات فيما افاد مسؤول من الامور
المتحده بعبور اكثر من 100 الف شخص حدود
السودان الى دول المجاوره حتى الان مؤكدا
ان الامم المتحده بحاجه الى واحد بل الى
مليار فاصل خمسه دولارات لتلبيه
الاحتياجات الانسانيه في السودان لهذا
العام
من جانبه قرر الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو تيريش ارسال منسق الاغاثه في حاله
الطوارئ ووكيل الامين العام للشؤون
الانسانيه الى السودان لاستكشاف سبل تقديم
الاغاثه الفوريه للملايين الاشخاص الذين
انقلبت حياتهم راسا على عقب بسبب القتال
الدائري في السودان
هذا واظهرت الصور نزوح عشرات الالاف من
الاشخاص عبر نيالا عاصمه جنوب دارفور مع
استمرار المواجهات
[موسيقى]
اكثر
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
منهم مشاهدينا ينضموا الينا الصحفي في
مكتب العربيه في السودان شهودي نادر اهلا
بك
المعلومات حول الاوضاع في ام درمان هل
تجنح الاوضاع نحو الهدوء ام التوتر
نعم
يستمر النسبي في مدينه
ام درمان بعد بعد يوم شهد قارات
بعد يوم شهد قارات جويه مكثفه
واصوات مضادات ارضيه قبل حوالي ساعه
الطيران الحربي
بعد حوالي ساعه عاود الله الطيران الحربي
التحليق بشكل لا مكثف في سماء مدينه ام
درمان اصوات المضادات عاودت ولكن في
المجمل يمضي اليوم بشكل حذر هناك حركه
بدات تنتظم الشوارع مدينه ام درمان منذ
يومين او ثلاثه ايام لكن ودى الاشاره الى
استمرار عمليات النهب من قبل مجموعات
متفلته اليوم منطقه حي العرب بجوار استادل
الهلال تلك المنطقه المشهوره غرب سوق
مدينه ام درمان شهدت عمليات النهب من قبل
مجموعات متفلته تضرر عدد من المخازن
والمحال التجاريه ماذا عن انتشار قوات
الشرطه يعني هل كان محدودا في مناطق
بعينها لماذا هناك استمرار لحاله نهب مع
الاعلان عن انتشار قوات الشرطه في مناطق
ام درمان والخرطوم
كما تعلم الشرطه بدا بدا نزولها في منطقه
جنوب الخرطوم بحسب اعلان وزاره الداخليه
السودانيه بان الانتشار سيكون بالتدريج
وبتنسيق مع القوات المسلحه حتى الان لم
تنزل الشرطه هنا الى شوارع مدينه ام درمان
متوقع او ربما تنزل في قضون الايام
المقبله ولكن حتى اليوم لا توجد لا يوجد
انتشار شرطي ملحوظ في شوارع مدينه ام
درمان خارطه انتشار وتمركزات الدعم السريع
في ام درمان هل تاثرت كثيرا بالغارات التي
يشنها الجيش السوداني منذ ايام
بحسب البيانات الصادره من الطرفين الدعم
السريعي اتهم القوات المسلحه بانه بانها
قد شنتها قصفا جويا على عدد من مواقعه في
عده مناطق في العاصمه بالامس تركزت
الاشتباكات في شرق مدينه درمان وكذلك
جنوبها الغربي سمع اصوات اشتباكات ابي
الاسلحه الخفيفه في منطقه
الفتحاب جنوب قرب مدينه ام درمان هي مناطق
تمركز ظلت محل مناوشات مستمره ما بين
الفينه الاخرى منذ اندلاع عمليات الاختتال
في الخامس عشر من ابريل
شكرا معنا الصحفي في مكتب العربيه في
السودان شهودي نادر شكرا شهدي
[موسيقى]
طبعا كل المراكز المعطله بحاجه الحرب
في هذه الظروف يعني صعبه وعدم امكانيات
بعض الادويه والمعدات
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات